but first we're going to begin this week
with news of more gun violence in this
country hitting close to home for more
and more americans since friday listen
to the numbers there have been 13
13 mass shootings in the u.s including
one in a busy part of philadelphia and
another outside a nightclub in
chattanooga where 14 people were shot
there two of them have died in another
sign that this is certainly on people's
minds players for both teams in the nba
they wore orange shirts last night with
a message n gun violence national
correspondent jericho duncan is in
philadelphia city she knows very well
jerica good morning to you what happened
there
well good morning to you gail you know
three people died here 12 were injured
in a mass shooting here in philadelphia
it happened on saturday along a very
busy south street familiar to a lot of
residents here a lot of businesses here
but hundreds were gathered at that time
police believe there were multiple
shooters involved and they also say it
appears it all started with an
altercation that clearly escalated
surveillance video shows the moment the
shooting unfolded
people running for their lives as
gunfire sprayed into the crowd i woke up
thinking i got to see what what happened
there maureen long says she heard the
gunshots from her apartment after
buffalo yuvaldi you know here right here
we have to do something it's a sentiment
echoed by the city's district attorney
larry krasner we have 120 guns for every
100 human beings that's ridiculous this
is supposed to be a country of human
beings not a country of guns 211
homicides so far this year
743 non-fatal shooting victims
what is a city to do
city is to change i mean that's the
bottom line
the latest cdc data reveals a nearly 35
percent increase in firearm deaths
nationwide from 2019 to 2020 with guns
accounting for 79 percent of all
homicides in the u.s the country also
recorded its most annual gun deaths ever
more than 45 thousand now into 2022
we're seeing increases in
many forms of violence
and of course we've seen some increases
in mass shootings as well daniel webster
leads the center for gun violence
solutions at johns hopkins university he
said gun violence has continued to rise
in the last two years and pointed to
reforms with wide public support like
tighter licensing laws and comprehensive
background checks as evidence-based
solutions the problem is the disconnect
between what the public say they want
and support and
what policy makers actually act upon
and experts say that the gun violence is
likely to tick up this summer as it
typically does as for the district
attorney larry krasner he tells me that
28 percent of fatal shootings are solved
making the point he says that people who
commit these crimes know they are likely
to get away with murder
all right thank you very much